,
REALLY, REALLY HORRIBLE STUFF.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Sean: THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORT.
PLEASE BE SAFE.
BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS, THEY
CONTINUE TO BLAME EVERYONE BUT
THEMSELVES FOR THE MOUNTING
CRISIS FACING THIS COUNTRY.
INFLATION IS AT A FRESH 40 YEAR
HIGH AS IT HAS NOW BEEN FOUR
MONTHS, AND THE PRICES OF
EVERYTHING YOU BUY IN EVERY
STORE YOU GO TO OUR WAY HIGHER.
THIS IS LONG BEFORE PUTIN
INVADED.
GAS PRICES, YOU FEEL THE PAIN AT
THE PUMP, HEATING YOUR HOME THIS
WINTER, YOU'RE PAYING A LOT MORE
THAN YOU ARE PAYING LAST YEAR
BUT IF YOU LISTEN TO THE
LEFT-WING SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEIR
ALLIES AND PRESS PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA MOB, IT'S ONLY BECAUSE OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THE DOG BITES, THE BEE STINGS,
YOU'VE BEEN FEELING SAD,
EVERYTHING THAT JOE SCREWS UP,
BLAME PUTIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT SINCE
PRESIDENT PUTIN BEGAN HIS
MILITARY BUILDUP ON UKRAINE
BORDERS, THE PRICE OF GAS AT THE
PUMP IN AMERICA HAS GONE UP
$0.75.
>> NO.
I MEAN, HE DID NOT CAUSE THE WAR
WHICH CAUSED PRICES TO SEARCH.
>> YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES SAY PUTIN'S PRICE
I.
>> PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE.
>> PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE IS A GREAT
WAY TO MESSAGE IT.
>> President Biden: I'M GOING
TO DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO
MINIMIZE PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE HERE
AT HOME.
>> Sean: OF COURSE FACT, TRUTH
ACTUALLY TELLS A VERY DIFFERENT
STORY.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S OWN
ECONOMIC DATA SHOWS THAT
INFLATION -- OH, LOOK AT THAT.
IT WAS SURGEON WELL BEFORE HE
INVADED UKRAINE.
GAS PRICES, THE PRICE OF USED
CARS, FOOD, BEVERAGE ALL HAVE
BEEN GOING UP SINCE JOEY GOT
INTO OFFICE AND WELL BEFORE
PUTIN LAUNCHED HIS BLOODY
ASSAULT AGAINST THE SOVEREIGN
COUNTRY UKRAINE.
BIDEN AND EVERY DEMOCRAT, THEY
ARE LYING TO YOU.
COSTS ARE SURGING BECAUSE OF HIS
FAILED ECONOMIC AND ENERGY
POLICIES.
THERE'S RECKLESS SPENDING AND OF
COURSE HIS ATTACKS, ALWAYS BLAME
THE AMERICAN OIL AND GAS SECTOR,
THEY ARE PLAYING DUMB AT MAKING
LESS MONEY ACCORDING TO
FOX BUSINESS.COM.
HERE TO EXPLAIN MORE,
LARRY KUDLOW.
I DON'T LIKE BEING LIED TO.
THE PUTIN PRICE HIKE AS IT
RELATES TO GAS IS B.S.
WE WERE ALREADY PAYING ALMOST
ABOUT 50 MORE A GALLON.
EVERYTHING WE BUY IN EVERY
STORE, WE HAVE BEEN PAYING MORE
FOR BECAUSE IT'S BEEN MONTH
AFTER MONTH AFTER MONTH OF 40
YEAR HIGH INFLATION.
VLADIMIR PUTIN DIDN'T CAUSE
THAT.
BUT THIS IS NOW THE NEW TALKING
POINT.
EXPLAIN FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
>> WELL, LOOK, I PULLED NUMBERS
THAT WILL HELP I THINK.
THERE'S A CERTAIN INFLATION
AMNESIA GOING ON WITH BIDEN ENDS
OF THE LEFT.
GASOLINE PRICES WERE $2.35 IN
JANUARY OF '1.
BY OCTOBER THEY WERE $3.31.
UP TO 40%.
THAT'S BEFORE PUTIN PUT ANY
TROOPS ON THE EAST SIDE OF THE
UKRAINE.
AND AS FAR AS THE WORLD PRICE
GOES, YOU ARE AT $52 IN JANUARY
'21 AND IT WAS $84 BY OCTOBER OF
A POSTURING 21.
THAT'S A 61% GAIN.
SO THAT'S BEFORE PUTIN SHOWED UP
AT ALL.
THOSE ARE HUGE NUMBERS.
THE INFLATION RATE, CONSUMER
PRICES, LESS THAN 2% IN DECEMBER
OF 2020 AND THEN IT GRADUALLY
SURGED TO THREE, 25, 27.5%
BEFORE PUTIN INVADED.
BY THE WAY, THE LATEST READINGS,
AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE PEAK
YET, THE LATEST READINGS FOR THE
CPI PLUS 8% YEAR ON YEAR.
WHOLESALE PRICES, SEAN, UP 10%
AND TODAY WE GOT A BEAUTY OR
YESTERDAY, IMPORT PRICES OF 11%
AND IT'S NOT OVER YET.
AND I THINK YOU WERE RIGHT.
THE SEEDS WERE PLANTED WITH A
HUGE BIG GOVERNMENT SOCIALIST
DEFICIT SPENDING PACKAGE OF
MARCH 2021, ABOUT ONE YEAR AGO.
AND THEN THEY SOLD ALL THAT
MONEY BY SELLING BONDS AND THE
FEDERAL RESERVE BOUGHT THE
BONDS, SO THE MONEY SUPPLY IS
SURGING INTO CONTINUES TO
SEARCH.
THE FED HASN'T DONE A THING.
SO WE ARE IN FOR A BIG PROBLEM
BUT THOSE SEEDS WERE PLANTED
OVER A YEAR AGO.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
GOLDMAN SACHS.
THEY ARE NOW PREDICTING IN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS AS MANY AS 11
INTEREST RATE HIKES FROM THE
FED.
ORIGINALLY THEY WERE PREDICTING
THREE OR FOUR THIS YEAR, THEN A
PREDICTED AS MANY AS 7 THIS
YEAR.
AS INTEREST RATES RISE, WHAT
WILL THAT DO TO THE ECONOMY
OVERALL?
WILL IT HELP WITH INFLATION?
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S GOING TO
PROBABLY HURT THE ECONOMY OR
THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
EVEN LAWRENCE SUMMERS NOW SAYING
THE LIKELIHOOD OF A RECESSION IS
PRETTY HIGH AT THIS POINT AND
MOST ECONOMISTS ARE SAYING THE
SAME THING.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I AGREE.
I THOUGHT WHAT LARRY SUMMERS
WROTE IN THE PAPER A COUPLE DAYS
AGO IS BASICALLY RIGHT.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE IN STAGFLATION.
THE FIRST QUARTER IS GOING TO
COME IN ABOUT 2% BUT THE
INFLATION RATE IS GOING TO BE
ABOUT 8%.
SO THAT IS STAGFLATION.
THAT'S NOT GOING AWAY.
INTEREST RATES ARE PROBABLY
GOING TO GO UP HIGHER THAN
ALMOST ANYBODY IS ANTICIPATING.
I MEAN, LOOK, IF YOU GOT 8%
INFLATION -- ACTUALLY, SUPPOSE
YOU HAD A 6% INFLATION RATE.
THE BASIC, BASIC INFLATION RATE.
INTEREST RATES ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO GO TO 7 OR 8% IN ORDER TO
QUELL THAT.
THE FEDS OF GOT TO STOP BUYING
BONDS AND I'VE GOT TO STOP
PRINTING MONEY.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN DONE YET.
SO ALL THESE ESTIMATES FROM
WALL STREET OR THE FED ARE WAY
TOO LOW.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO SEE AN
ENORMOUS INCREASE IN INTEREST
RATES, AND YES, THAT IS GOING TO
LEAD TO A RECESSION, THE MIDDLE
CLASS, THE WORKING FOLKS ARE
GOING TO BEAR THE BRUNT OF THAT.
THEIR REAL WAGES ARE ALREADY
FALLING AND IT'S GOING TO BE
WORSE THAN THAT.
IT'S A TRAGEDY BECAUSE I WILL
TELL YOU THIS, SEAN.
AS A PROUD ALUMNUS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, WE LEFT THEM
WITH A SOLID V-SHAPED RECOVERY,
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, AND
VIRTUALLY NO INFLATION.
AND IN ONE YEAR PLUS THEY HAVE
WRECKED THE WHOLE ECONOMIC
STORY.
IT'S A TRAGEDY.
>> Sean: THE CPI WAS 1.4%, NOW
IT'S 7.9.
THERE IS YOUR INFLATION.
IF WE USE THE OLD METHOD BACK IN
THE CARTER YEARS INFLATION WOULD
BE AT 16%, IT WOU